bonsoir
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 21 juin comme depuis 20 ans le
premier jour de l'été fait la musique
toutes les musiques à la ville comme à
la campagne de lille à paris nous
verrons comment et puis n'oubliez pas
une soirée de musique en direct avec
michel drucker sur france 2 ce soir la
justice condamne pour faute inexcusable
les chantiers de l'atlantique dans trois
dossiers de victimes de l'amiante
d'autres victimes de l'amiante dans les
locaux de l'université de jussieu seront
indemnisés les verts en proie à des
luttes intestines près la victoire
surprise alain lipietz à la candidature
présidentielle premier congrès mondial
contre la peine de mort à strasbourg il
ya désormais une véritable ligne de
partage entre les abolitionnistes et les
autres comme la chine et les états unis
exclusivité france 2 avant sa venue
officielle en france lundi le président
syrien bachar al assad nous accorder un
entretien le premier depuis son arrivée
au pouvoir après la mort de son père il
ya un an
bachar al assad évoque le départ de
l'armée syrienne du liban et la
reconnaissance d'israël
et après un ultime des tours en direct
d'une fête de la musique avec michel mon
compte elle nous évoquerons la
préparation de l'équipe de france de
rugby pour son deuxième test match
contre les springboks sont en afrique du
sud à d'urban samedi prochain 20 ans
quel bel âge pour une belle idée du à
jack lang en 1981 une idée qui a fait le
tour du monde celle d'une fête de toutes
les musiques
alors ce soir on sort les instruments on
chante entre vedettes ou entre anonyme
solitaire ou encore halle le premier
jour de l'été a le bon goût un peu
partout en france d'être beau aussi la
soirée s'annonce tel à l'unisson
revue de détail musicale avec daniel
wolfromm yves jacques à et sébastien man
oiseaux
pour fêter l'été la musique les arènes
de lutèce servent de décor à deux
chorales gigantesque
cinq cents élèves mobilisés des mois de
travail et la reconnaissance des
professionnels pour des enfants au goût
éclectique plonger dans le xiiie siècle
avec ses chants en latin tirer des
carmina burana contraste à la république
les répétitions du groupe de rock
allemand scorpions
mon couple coule les premiers amateurs
ont pris place aux carrefours
une ministre descend de son ministère
pour saluer un chanteur alors valence et
valence et 25 fête de la musique c'est
un beau démenti à la mauvaise réputation
des français dans ton nadine très
longtemps qui n'aimait pas la musique la
pratique est pas le chanteur c'est
jacques olivier leader des têtes raides
et père spirituel de toute une
génération de musiciens français
de remplir nos horloges de changer au
musée de tiercé de brioches vite du
pêchereau
chantant là
les soldats justement les voilà pour une
aubade sur le champ de mars de la
fanfare du 1er régiment de spahis et le
soir peut tomber
la fête peut vraiment commencer voilà il
nous faut vraiment celle mompontet la
fin de cette émission en direct près de
l'assemblée nationale il ya déjà des
milliers de personnes c'est une première
procédure judiciaire qui en appelle
certainement d'autres le tribunal des
affaires de sécurité sociale de nantes
reconnu la faute inexcusable des
chantiers de l'atlantique dans trois
dossiers de victimes de l'amiante les
indemnités versées seront largement
majorées et cette décision fera sans nul
doute jurisprudence commentaires
sébastien leguay avec jacques devaux la
faute des chantiers de l'atlantique est
inexcusable
cette formule dur éloquente possède un
sens juridique précis les précautions
n'ont pas été prises pour protéger les
salariés d'un risque sanitaire de
l'amiante en l'occurrence michel fleury
l'un des trois plaignants sera donc
indemnisé
cet homme a perdu beaucoup de ses
capacités respiratoires pour avoir
travaillé trente neuf ans aux côtés
d'ouvriers qui isolait les tuyaux avec
de l'amiante pour et manqué des taux
longs c'était la muse qui nous tombait
dessus pardon qu est ce qu on allait sur
le dos rond et autant les ponts respirer
j'espère pour lui depuis 1972 les
dépistages révèle que 1500 salariés des
chantiers de l'atlantique ont développé
des maladies liées à l'amiante
la décision du tribunal des affaires de
la sécurité sociale pourrait entraîner
de nombreuses autres procédures
lorsque l'on voit son ancien collègue
obtenir la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de son employeur
ça vous motive à faire de même fait que
d'autres dossiers autre décision 11
victimes de la faculté de jussieu seront
également indemniser il y a un an un
jugement du tribunal de paris les priés
d'attendre peut-être longtemps
aujourd'hui il gagne en appel même si
personne n'est condamné même si le
montant des indemnisations n'est pas
encore défini
nantes comme à paris pour les défenseurs
des victimes de l'amiante
ce sont quand même deux victoires
jumelles et symbolique
on reconnaît la responsabilité à la fois
des employeurs qu'ils soient du secteur
privé ou du secteur public et même en ce
qui concerne jussieu ça met en cause
directement l'état aujourd'hui en france
plus de 2000 procédure d'indemnisation
sont en cours le désamiantage de jussieu
ordonné en 1996 mais guère plus rapide
les travaux sont encore loin d'être
terminée dans la lutte engagée contre
les cancers et pour un meilleur
dépistage la nouvelle machine d'imagerie
médicale qui vient d'être mise au point
à zurich à l'hôpital universitaire
marque un réel progrès cet appareil
permet en effet de mieux localiser les
tumeurs cancéreuses y compris les plus
ténus ce qui améliorera le diagnostic
benoît thevenet bedredine a obtenu
l'exclusivité de la présentation de ce
nouvel appareil
il répond au doux nom de pet ct
il n'existe pour l'instant qu'en deux
exemplaires l'un se trouve aux états
unis l'autre ici à zurich
cet appareil combine de technologie
celle du scanner qui fonctionnent avec
des rayons x
c'est l'image à gauche de votre écran et
celle du pet scan au centre qui permet
de repérer une activité anormale des
cellules
à droite la machine à fusionner les deux
images pour les obtenir
on injecte aux patients une solution de
glucose légèrement radioactif se sucrent
va aller se fixer sur les zones qui en
consomment le plus elles apparaissent en
noir à l'écran il s'agit du cerveau du
coeur mais aussi des tumeurs cancéreuses
c'est le cas chez cet homme en
fusionnant cette image avec celle du
scanner qui fait apparaître la structure
interne du corps l'appareil permet de
localiser précisément la tumeur dans le
poumon
ce petit point jaunes sur l'écran je
pense que pour le patient l'avantagent
de cette machine de pouvoir situer plus
précisément la tumeur
et définir ainsi un traitement plus
adapté le nouvel appareil permet d'avoir
une vision globale du corps et de
repérer d'éventuels métastases on
progresse ici par tranches de 5 mm en
bas au centre la colonne vertébrale
l'examen fait apparaître la tumeur
primaire dans le poumon à gauche en
progressant on découvre ensuite une
métastase dans la colonne vertébrale
nous estimons que sur 50 patients nous
avons fait 47 fois le bon diagnostic 103
cas seulement nous avons commis une
légère erreur sur l'étendue réelle du
cancer des résultats améliorés de 60%
par rapport à ce que permettent les
autres techniques d'imagerie mais la
machine un coût plus de 21 millions de
francs
la france n'a pour l'instant pas passer
commande les verts sont depuis hier dans
les délices d'une bataille familiale
à peine remis de la surprise causée par
l'élection d'alain lipietz comme
candidat à la présidentielle aux dépens
de noël mamère il leur faut maintenant
revoir tous leurs équilibres internes y
compris celui qui devait permettre à
dominique voynet saint-denis de
reprendre la direction du mouvement
reportage alban nicosie et arnaud boutet
parler de tout et de n'importe quoi sauf
de la pagaille interne aux écologistes
vers 16 heures cet après midi dominique
voynet achève un long tête à tête avec
lionel jospin au programme les
conséquences pour la gauche de la
nouvelle donne chez les verts la porte
qui claque signifie que les conclusions
ne seront pas rendues publiques
alain lipietz désigné hier candidat des
verts noël mamère battu d'une courte
tête et voilà le parti plongez dans un
de ces psychodrames dont il a le secret
les dix mille militants se divise en
cinq temps dans celle de dominique
voynet rassemble un tiers celle de noël
mamère un quart
or samedi en conseil national dominique
voynet souhaite se faire élire à la tête
du mouvement
alain lipietz candidat à la
présidentielle yves cochet probable
futur ministre les amis de dominique
voynet aurait tous les pouvoirs
alors certains cadres menace dominique
voynet d'un vote négatif
vraiment si ce n'est les charges de 30 %
et que je sais pas si quelqu'un
aujourd'hui que assuré qu'il y aura 60%
donc je crois que la prudence paix
dressler de recaler l'ensemble du
dispositif mouvement campagne suite à
l'événement d'hier reporter l'élection
du secrétaire national à septembre noël
mamère n'y est pas favorable
il souhaite ne pas mettre d'huile sur le
feu pourra-t-il convaincre ses amis
c'est bien là la question
l'euro à petit par le dernier pas et
postales voici le premier timbre
représentant mme euros il était présenté
par laurent fabius aujourd'hui sera
commercialisé à partir de lundi prochain
il est rond il était mis au tarif de 3
francs évidemment soit 0 46 euro 15
millions d'exemplaires ont été imprimés
de ce premier tome euros
c'est une date importante pour le combat
contre la peine de mort dans le monde un
premier congrès contre la peine capitale
se tient à strasbourg
jacques chirac a apporté son soutien 86
pays maintiennent des exécutions dans
leur législation ou dans leurs pratiques
et 65 d'entre eux ont prononcé des
peines capitales en l'an 2000 la chine
bat tous les plus sinistres record mais
la démocratie américaine n'est pas en
reste dans ce domaine l'explication anne
consigny in russia aux condamnés pour
terrorisme en mars exécutés en avril
ainsi va la peine de mort en chine vite
et fort surtout comme ces derniers mois
lors de l'opération frapper fort destiné
à lutter contre la criminalité en deux
mois
exécutions la chine pays le plus peuplé
du monde est aussi celui qui exécute le
plus il n'y a pas de chiffres officiels
mais selon les comptages des
organisations humanitaires mille chinois
ont été passés par les armes l'an
dernier vient ensuite l'arabie saoudite
avec 123 exécution un nombre très
important par rapport à sa population de
18 millions d'habitants
suivent les états unis 85 exécution et
l'iran 75
ces quatre pays ont procédé à plus des
trois quarts des exécutions mondiale au
total ils sont 86 à avoir conservé la
peine de mort dans leur code pénal mais
certains ne l'appliquent plus la russie
par exemple a décrété un moratoire en 96
le pays est sur la voie de l'abolition
mais les partisans de la peine de mort
n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot
en fait le débat reste très vive dans de
nombreux pays et particulièrement aux
états unis
cet homme juan raul garcia est le
dernier à y avoir été exécutés
avant-hier 85 personnes ont subi le même
sort aux états unis l'an dernier dont 40
dans le seul état du texas
l'abolitionnisme progresse aux états
unis notamment chaque fois qu'un
condamné à mort est reconnu innocent est
sauvé mais globalement l'opinion
publique américaine reste
majoritairement favorables à la peine
capitale
la prochaine exécution est prévue demain
dans l'état de l'alabama à strasbourg de
nombreux témoignages d'ex combat d'un
mort qui ont réussi à prouver leur
innocence et a échappé la chaise
électrique ou à l'injection létale en
vogue aux etats-unis sont venus une
nouvelle fois démontré que les erreurs
judiciaires et est toujours possible et
que pour cette seule simple raison la
peine de mort n'est pas acceptable
reportage à strasbourg christine bost et
sylvain gauthier condamné à mort dans
leur pays respectif victimes d'erreurs
judiciaires ils ont été innocentés
après avoir connu l'enfer ça calme end à
34 ans de prison au japon antoinette
chahine cinq ans dans les geôles
libanaises qu'elles wimax cook 22 ans
dans les couloirs de la mort au texas
accueilli en 1977 du meurtre d'une
voisine il est condamné m
or après un procès expéditif dans
l'antichambre de la mort à lille il se
bat pour prouver son innocence
j'avais juste en moi la certitude d'être
innocent si je ne mettais pas défendu
tout seul le reste du monde et en
particulier mon propre pays ne se serait
pas battu pour moi innocente et en 1999
grâce à un test adn karl max cook
réapprend la vie marié et papa d'un
petit garçon prénommé kai justice il est
aujourd'hui un des plus ardents
abolitionniste amérique
si vous êtes pauvres ou noir si vous
appartenez à une minorité
si vous n'avez pas de l'argent pour
payer un avocat vous avez toutes les
chances d'être condamné à mort aucune
personne riche et blanche ne se trouve
dans les couloirs de la mort au texas
pendant ma détention j'ai vu sur
quarante et un homme et une femme être
exécuté josé giovanni romancier et
réalisateur est un de ces miraculés
condamné à mort en 1949 pour un
règlement de comptes entre gangsters
il sera gracié puis réalité aujourd'hui
avec son dernier film il rend hommage à
son père qui lui a sauvé la vie
il était parler aux familles des
victimes pour présenter son fils ou à
nos jours et demandé le pardon implorant
le pardon pour son fils donc c'est la
plaidoirie la plus difficile à faire
évidemment le plus efficace aussi j'ai
eu le pardon famille coupable comme lui
ou innocent comme car wimax coux et ex
condamnés à mort sont aujourd'hui les
partisans les plus efficaces de
l'abolition de la peine de mort une
éclipse de soleil comparable à celle que
les européens ont connu en 1999 obscurci
depuis quelques heures le ciel de
plusieurs pays de l'afrique australe et
de l'océan indien
c'est une équipe qui couvre une bande de
200 km de large environ
on rappellera que ce phénomène n'est
possible qu'avec l'alignement parfait
terre lune soleil qui permet de voir
avec toutes les précautions d'usagé mais
sur l lunettes spéciales
les éruptions solaires vous avez encore
en tête certainement ses formidables
images que nous avons vues notamment des
nuits des étoiles avec hubert reeves il
y a deux ans alors nous envoyés spéciaux
eric meunier roger mode se trouvaient à
madagascar pour observer avec plusieurs
milliers de malgaches cette équipe du
soleil avec quelques nuages mais
évidemment la même fascination qu en
france il ya deux ans à madagascar
c'est le signal celui d'un rang b à
yousse dans le sud du pays
les rues se sont vidées les têtes
chaussée de fameuses lunettes se tourner
vers le soleil les clips ça commence
dans un village des alentours
réfugié à nyon pour père de famille un
procède à la distribution
la caisse de prévoyance locale lui a
offert les lunettes et longuement
expliqué le danger pour lui et ses
enfants a exposé leurs yeux au sol est
ici
le message est passé il n'y a plus guère
que son vieux père pour s'inquiéter
encore du phénomène
vous avez peur oui monsieur dieu encore
une demi heure et le soleil disparaîtra
deux minutes et 32 secondes exactement à
une quinzaine de kilomètres de là ce
plateau devrait offrir le plus beau des
spectacles
ils sont quelques milliers à avoir fait
le voyage de la capitale antananarivo
d'europe ou de plus loin encore chez les
rats zana qu on est venu en famille n'y
a plus de 20 des quatre coins de l'île
on est heureux parce que toute la
famille l'avant quand partie de la
famille ont donné une occasion c'est la
fête bon c'est pas lolo quand même si on
sent pas éclipse totale sous nuage
craintes confirmées et la sq
à 16h28 heures du rendez vous un épais
nuage masquer les clips staut a visé
klaxons peine alors à cacher la
déception
vraiment c'est décevant quoi ou bien
sachez qu'une fatalité ou bien c'est
quoi rêve avec un jour ici on difficile
de tous les jours et la extrêmement
dommage ah oui très déçu la prochaine
éclipse totale aura lieu le 4 décembre
2002 en afrique australe et en océanie
pour patienter les amateurs peuvent
toujours admirer les couchers de soleil
de madagascar garantit toutes les 24
heures
violents affrontements la nuit dernière
à belfast en irlande du nord dans un
quartier partagé entre les deux
communautés protestantes et catholiques
les troubles ont commencé lorsque des
loyalistes protestants ont jeté des
pierres sur des nationalistes
catholiques qui conduisaient leurs
enfants dans une école primaire
l'armée et la police sont intervenus un
appel au calme été lancée ce matin 39
policiers auraient été blessés lors de
ces violences à belfast en algérie
malgré les déclarations du président de
l'asic bouteflika se prononçant pour le
dialogue de nouveaux incidents ont
éclaté aujourd'hui à tizi ouzou en
kabylie des jeunes ont érigé des
barricades et jeté des pierres sur la
police
nos envoyés spéciaux girard griesbeck et
jean françois le masne témoin de
funérailles de l'une des victimes des
émeutes récentes raconte l'extrême
tension qui règne en ce moment en
kabylie
tous les hommes du village sont qu'une
fois de plus les yeux et une fois de
plus c'est pour enterrer l'un des leurs
samir avait 19 ans son jeune frère
n'arrive toujours pas à réaliser
samir a été écrasé par une voiture de
gendarmes écrasé volontairement dit les
témoins du drame
il y aura passé je suis trois fois dans
le dos qui l'ont 1 qu'il en a et quillan
prix ils l'ont emmené à l'hôpital
entre douleur et colère la full circle
une dernière fois pour entonner un chant
funèbre avant que le corps de samy on ne
soient ensevelies à même la terre comme
le veut la tradition et c'est alors que
les premiers slogans fusent
il n'y aura pas de pardon créé la foule
c'est aussi la réponse au discours du
président bouteflika car ici on ne
comprend pas pourquoi le président a
choisi de faire une tournée dans le sud
du pays à 2000 km de la kabylie
loin des grandes villes dans ces
milliers de petits villages de kabylie
les jeunes affrontent aussi tous les
jours les gendarmes et le discours du
président bouteflika ne semble pas avoir
apaisé la colère le président syrien
bachar al assad sera en visite
officielle en france pour trois jours à
partir de lundi
c'est une grande première pour lui
bachar al assad nous a accordé un
entretien télévisé enregistré dans son
palais présidentiel de damas avant de
vous proposer cet entretien et nous a
semblé utile nécessaire avec pascal
golomer de donner quelques éléments de
la situation politique de la syrie dans
cette région du monde à commencer par
l'opération de ré redéploiement voire de
retrait d'une partie de l'armée syrienne
du liban
s'agit-il vraiment d'une coïncidence à
quelques jours de la visite de bachar
el-assad en france les forces syriennes
viennent de quitter beyrouth
elles y avaient pris position il ya 25
ans au début de la guerre civile au
liban
trente cinq mille soldats syriens se
sont depuis installés dans le pays une
omniprésence militaire mais aussi
politique et économique que dénoncent de
plus en plus de libanais mais damas
n'envisagera un retrait total de ses
troupes que dans le cadre plus large
les négociations de paix avec israël
négociations au point mort parce
qu'aucun accord n'est possible
aujourd'hui
à propos du plateau du golan un
territoire syrien conquis par israël en
dix sept mille juifs y vivent
aujourd'hui dans des colonies la syrie
exige qu'israël se retire
mais jusqu'où
c'est à propos du tracé de la frontière
que porte le différend entre les deux
pays
l'enjeu c'est l'accès à la vallée du
jourdain est essentielle pour
l'alimentation en eau de toute la région
sur ce point bachar el-assad n'a fait
que reprendre les positions de son père
auquel il a succédé il ya tout juste un
an à l'intérieur de son pays il a un
mort c'est très prudemment la
libéralisation de l'économie le
développement du secteur privé
l'ouverture politique en revanche est
encore bien timide
le chef de l'état doit sans cesse
arbitrer entre la vieille garde
accroché au pouvoir et le désir de
changement de la nouvelle génération
alors les propos que vous allez entendre
du président syrien répondre aux
questions relatives donc au retrait du
liban israël à l'évolution du régime de
damas dans son palais présidentiel
imposant le jeune président bachar al
assad il a 36 ans a joué le jeu de
l'entretien sans aucun préalable il
comprend très bien le français pour
avoir fait ses études au lycée français
de damas un an quasiment jour pour jour
après le décès de son père il sans
vouloir engager son pays dans une
ouverture prioritairement économique
ma première question était lié à
l'actualité le retrait de l'armée
syrienne ces derniers jours du divan
annonçait-il un retrait total que le
lacroix l'armée syrienne est entrée au
liban pour une mission bien définie dans
tous les discours ou les déclarations
des responsables syriens comme le
président hafez el-assad par le passé
aujourd'hui il n'y a jamais eu une
déclaration qu'ils nient ce fait la
présence militaire syrienne au liban est
provisoire un jour l'armée syrienne se
retira du liban et ce jour vous pensez
que
voyez proches c'est évident puisque le
lieu de déploiement de l'armée syrienne
et le territoire de la syrie
quant à la date du retrait est
entièrement liée aux conjonctures
internes du liban et aux conditions
régionales le président vous êtes en
impliqué directement dans la situation
générale de cette région du monde dans
le proche orient
pouvez vous nous dire si vous pensez
qu'un jour vous signerez un accord de
paix avec israël et que vous
reconnaîtrez israël ont syrie comme dans
toute la région que je suis comme tout
peuple arabe nous souhaitons la paix et
nous en parlons tous les jours nous
devrons aussi pour la paix c'est notre
but est notre espoir aux as
le résultat normal de cette paix globale
et juste qui viendra après des
négociations équitables
wormhout haouaria après la signature de
l'accord de paix équitable
c'est une reconnaissance de l'état
d'israël
à condition qu'ils soient capables
d'offrir cette est réelle mais vous
monsieur le président vous êtes près un
jour à signer la paix avec israël et à
reconnaître l'état d'israël je les dis
clairement quand il y aura une paix
globale et juste qui restitue à chacun
ses droits dans la région la
reconnaissance devient naturel c'est à
dire qu'il peut y avoir des relations
normales et naturelle comme celle qui
existe entre les deux états entre deux
peuples
pensez vous que ce soit possible avec
monsieur sharon filtre marno nous ne
donnons aucune importance le personnel
même en israël
mad brochure ne voulons pas intervenir
dans les affaires intérieures
israéliennes
notre problème consiste à récupérer les
droits reconnus par toutes les instances
internationales
soutenez-vous yasser arafat on a le
sentiment que vous soutenez la cause
palestinienne des mouvements
palestiniens mais que vous
et quelques réticences quelques
critiques dans la manière dont monsieur
arafat
même le combat c'est vrai nous soutenons
la cause palestinienne et nous traitons
de façon générale avec les causes phase
avec les personnes comme je viens de le
dire
nous soutenons tous les moyens qui
permettront de faire valoir les droits
du peuple palestinien nous cherchons à
établir une paix réelle pas seulement un
accord nous faisons la différence entre
les deux ce qui se passe actuellement
prouve que nous avons raison j'ai
rencontré monsieur arafat en marge du
sommet je lui ai confirmé que la
position syrienne reste inchangé j'ai
confirmé que je maintenais toujours la
même politique depuis que la royale en
tout cas les divergences entre deux
personnes ne peuvent pas les empêcher de
se rencontrer et de discuter de leur
point de vue quelle est la condition de
la paix pour vous si rien c'est la
restitution du goal ans et plus que cela
notre position est claire mamelon le
volant qui est un territoire syrien
mais il existe un malentendu à sourire
certains demandent quelles sont les
conditions syrienne je voudrais faire
ici la différence votre condition et
droit en réalité la syrie n'impose pas
de conditions mais elle a des droits
je dis que non droit sont claires et
évidentes reconnu par toutes les
instances internationales au fica de ce
président des propos que vous avez tenus
au moment de la visite du pape ont
beaucoup choqué en europe
vous avez dit que le racisme en israël
avait surpassé le nazisme
est-ce que vous votre langue et fo suez
ce que vous vous êtes trompés ce que
vous êtes sentiment que vous avez été
mal compris on a du mal nous européens
nous français à comprendre que vous
puissiez assimilé le nazisme à israël la
kfor finalement il ya une différence
entre assimilés et comparer l assimiler
sait mettre les choses sur le même plan
moi j'ai juste fait une comparaison je
les fais dans mon discours au sommet
arabe n'est pas devant sa sainteté le
pardon j'ai parlé du racisme d'israël à
travers les meurtres qu'il a commis
pendant l'intifada savoie en trial et
qu'il a commis depuis sa création
dans ce discours devant le pad
je n'ai pas parlé de racisme pour le
faire dans ce prop
j'ai parlé des valeurs dans les
religions dit que la souffrance du
christ ressemble à la souffrance du
peuple palestinien
actuellement en palestine et que le
complot organisé qu'a subies le prophète
mahomet est le même que celui que
pratique israël depuis le début des
négociations pour la paix évidemment il
ya eu un tollé dans la presse
occidentale
enfin m'a fait dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit sur le compte des juifs ceci est en
contradiction avec ce que je crois m je
suis avant tout un citoyen musulmans et
l'islam reconnaît la religion chrétienne
et la religion juive trois religions
étant issus du même dieu ce président
vous êtes un jeune président il y a un
an vous avez succédé à votre père on a
parlé du printemps de damas on a parlé
d'une ère nouvelle
elle est en même temps on a le sentiment
qu'il ya eu un ralentissement dans ce
que vous avez voulu entreprendre c'est à
dire une marche vers une démocratie
quel est l'état des lieux aujourd'hui
provient il est normal qu'il y ait des
difficultés au début de tout projet ou
toute démarche existe des obstacles
objectifs et d'autres non objectifs ces
derniers sont souvent liés à des
personnes des opportunistes des
personnes dont les propres intérêts
s'opposent au changement
certains même sans le vouloir mais il
faut aussi tenir compte des éléments
liés à certaines valeurs de la société
le président vous venez en visite
officielle en france
qu'attendez-vous de la france
qu'attendez-vous de l'europe et vous le
sentiment que la france peut jouer un
rôle particulier à l'égard de la série à
l'égard du proche-orient france alors
s'offrir la france en particulier un
statut privilégié du fait qu'elle est
présent lui dans cette région depuis des
centaines d'années pour talibans ce soit
en syrie où ailleurs dans les pays
arabes
il est certain que nos relations avec la
france ont toujours été très bonne
depuis le général de gaulle qui a
soutenu clairement les causes arabes et
jusqu'à monsieur chirac
nous espérons qu'il en sera toujours
ainsi
merci monsieur le président nous avons
accordé cet entretien
merci pour vos et bienvenue dans ses
rues voilà entretien préparé par thierry
thuillier et jean-paul beaumont réalisé
par tristan nolin à damas au palais
présidentiel aujourd'hui des comités de
défense des droits de l'homme révéler
qu'ils étaient sans nouvelles du
journaliste syrien militant de droits de
l'homme nizar nayyouf il aurait pu être
enlevée mais les autorités syriennes
démentent affirmant qu'un tel agissement
n'était pas de leur intérêt alors que le
président al assad vient en france lundi
et puis honneur à notre excellent
correspondant en allemagne patrie strom
même il vient de recevoir le prix franco
allemand du journalisme pour son enquête
diffusés dans envoyé spécial sur
l'extrémisme néo nazis dans la publique
fédérale allemande bravo à battre le
quinze de france en afrique du sud à
d'urban samedi entend bien rééditer son
exploit de la semaine dernière les bleus
avaient battu les springboks
mais le défi physique promis par les
sud-africains sonne comme une volonté de
revanche et le 15
entraînée par bernard laporte est resté
très concentré toute cette semaine
commentaire julien beaumont avec
jean-françois renou pas vraiment frileux
le quinze de france sur le sable
sud-africain un petit bain dans l'océan
indien températures à peine 17 degrés
de quoi faire réfléchir david skréla on
les croirait presque en vacances
leur façon à eux d'évacuer la pression
avant le prochain test match samedi
vainqueur la semaine dernière les
français se préparent à subir des
représailles
on peut pas vexer plus heures un
springbok après après le match de samedi
dernier donc pour sa part évidemment une
grosse réaction d'orgueil de leur part
mais je pense que durant toute la
semaine on a même mis beaucoup
d'application dans l'antre d'un autre
jeu et on essaiera de répondre au mieux
à l'agressivité sud africaine cette
agressivité sud africaine fabien galthié
on a déjà vu la couleur
football du springbok andrews dès le
premier match bilan un nez cassé côté
français chaude ambiance
d'autant que le numéro 5 a annoncé qu'il
ne comptait pas en rester là
quant à l'antenne aux à fabien galthié
je vais te casser la mâchoire
c'est pas le genre de guerre et qui
n'ont qui nous excite et qui est que
nous trouvons honorable donc je crois
que nous nous concentrerons certainement
à mai à faire la guerre aussi mais la
guerre
avec tout cela comporte de nobles les
français sont prévenus
alors ils se sont entraînés en
conséquence séance musclée à durban dans
le sud du pays
bernard laporte présente la même équipe
que samedi dernier une équipe jeune
rapide
voilà justement ce qui pourrait faire la
différence lors du prochain face à face
en football la direction nationale de
contrôle et de gestion a donné quitus à
l'om qui reste en première division mais
pas toulouse relégué en national les
dirigeants tous n'ont pas accepté le
troc qui leur étaient proposés ils
maintiennent leur recours en conseil
d'état à propos des faux passeports des
joueurs de certaines équipes évoluant en
première division ce qui pourrait
bouleverser le classement du dernier
championnat
explications avec isabelle de léon leurs
clubs sanctionnés
c'est un scandale disent les dirigeants
du tfc et il dénonce les pratiques des
instances du football
après trois heures de discussions le
président de la commission qui se
reconnaîtra nous a posé le marché
suivant voulait jouer en d2
vous voulez que vos comptes soit admis
en d2 c'est bien il faut en terminer
tout de suite suffit de signer un papier
par lequel vous renoncer au recours
devant le conseil d'état
nous irons nous mêmes la porter au
conseil d'état l affaire est réglée
jusqu'à présent très discret ses
dirigeants affirment aujourd'hui avoir
subi de nombreuses pressions pour clore
la faire des faux passeports
on leur demandait d'accepter la loi du
milieu selon mr il faudrait mener ou
wendel on est en france and democracy
le souci c'est qu'on s'est sauvé la mise
avec le soutien in extremis d'alain
afflelou l'opticien ne voulait pas mêlé
son nom un scandale mais là il s'emporte
et le scandale vient pas de toulouse la
voilà j'en atteste je suis témoin je
peux dire que ces messieurs ont sué sang
et eau depuis huit jours pour que le tfc
vive l'entraînement doit reprendre lundi
mais le vrai match se jouera au conseil
d'état en pleine fête de la musique les
responsables politiques écrivent une
partition cacophonique pour ou contre
une législation des rave parties
la proposition du rpr thierry magnier
mariani un instant relayé par le
ministère de l'intérieur est apparu
comme liberticide pour les jeunes
rappeurs et la gauche ainsi que des
neiges aux plaintes cherchent maintenant
prudemment une voie de sortie
commentaires laurence ostolaza avec
stéphane morel
lionel jospin a choisi la fête de la
musique pour donner le la à question de
légiférer tout de suite il faut d'abord
dialoguer et trouver un compromis entre
liberté sécurité à l'origine de ce
charivari un homme thierry mariani
député rpr
le 27 avril son amendement qui prô nant
meilleur contrôle des rave parties est
adoptée grâce surprise aux voix de
gauche
mieux encore un mois plus tard
l'amendement est soutenu par le ministre
socialiste de l'intérieur daniel
vaillant approuve ainsi une législation
beaucoup plus répressive est un
véritable encadrement
il ya deux jours encore il affichait sa
fermeté il n'est de liberté véritable
sans contrainte et sans règles respect
des choses et respect des autres
mais d'ailleurs surprenante volte-face
les députés ps désavoue le ministre en
refusant de légiférer sur les red party
il se prononce pour le statu quo
c'est-à-dire pour une relative liberté
sous la vigilance des préfets pourquoi
donc un tel revirement
selon le député thierry mariani il
s'agit avant tout de ne pas perdre un
certain électorat
je crois qu'en politique certains sont
un peu malade de la dhea c'est à dire
que doivent se lever tous les matins en
lisant pour gagner les élections qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour paraître aussi
jeune que les jeunes plus jeunes que les
jeunes à la fronde des députés
socialistes s'ajoute une division au
sein même du gouvernement puisque le
ministre de l'éducation nationale lui
non plus ne veut pas légiférer moi je
suis favorable toujours sur ce sujet
comme sur tant d'autres non pas des
textes décider soit par le gouvernement
soit par le parlement mais à un dialogue
et une charte ce soir le chef
d'orchestre a donc tenté de mettre fin à
la cacophonie ambiante la partition se
jouera mardi prochain à l'assemblée
la fête de la musique la vraie à lille
le concert s'est depuis 20h ressemblent
en ce moment à une pièce musicale avec
ray lema musiciens africains metteur en
scène et une trentaine d'enfants d'un
quartier lillois issus pour la plupart
de l'immigration à mme mourgues et
patrick personnes ont regardé et écouté
ray lema et ces jeunes adeptes pour une
répétition ultime d'une musique sans
frontières la musique de terry
d'habitude c'est plutôt le hip hop ils
l'écoutent sur sa vieille radio histoire
de tuer le temps c'est à gauche de la
cité ici les races et les couleurs se
mélangent
ce soir c'est un grand jour serait-il
donc j'ai un peu le trac mon siège
central
parfois je me fiche la chaîne fierobe
mais moi je commence donc si moi je dis
nous allons chanter pour la fête de la
musique c'est un autre rythme qui
l'emportent venus du fond de l'afrique
noire
dernière répétition ce soir il jouera
sur scène du jazz b dans un cancer écrit
pour lui et ses copains par un virtuose
de la musique africaine monsieur ray les
bah c'est sûr mamerow faire un un
quartier je ne sais pas pur blanc oui
faut bien pur noire j'aurais été un peu
embarrassée parce que mais je suis très
métissée à l'intérieur de moi avec
rodrigue révérence suppression d'un bond
du voyage de l'ensica l'occident une
musique sans frontières mélange subtil
des instruments et des rites sa musique
leur ouvre de nouveaux horizons
glv à a
apprendre des trucs faux pas prêt montre
à tout le monde
par exemple quand j'habitais cnb va
s'opérer
dans un cas sur
je suis tout salir et aux à lire la
musique c'est tous les jours à toutes
les heures donc quand je vois une fois
l'an les français qui se met en transe
pour faire la musique je trouve c'est
déjà un grand progrès progrès mais vous
pouvez faire mieux quoi alors c'est
robin ne s'arrêtera pas à tous et sur sa
vieille radio
c'est la tante autres visible qu'un qui
pourraient voilà on va retrouver l'un
des grands musiciens de la rédaction de
france 2 michel mompontet 20 en deux
sets de la musique donc beaucoup
beaucoup de projets mon cher michel
effectivement claude bienvenue sur cette
esplanade de l'assemblée nationale au
coeur de paris on vous n'êtes pas tout
seul et je ne suis pas tout seul
derrière moi plus de dix mille personnes
déjà pour assister au concert du multi
instrumentiste et yann tiersen vous
savez yann tiersen c'est le formidable
musicien qui a écrit la bande annonce de
la fa bu du fabuleux destin pardon
d'amélie poulain que bien sûr vous avez
vu alors souvenez-vous que tu veux sans
faire dans ces combattants c'était le 21
juin 1982 j'avais 17 kilos en moins et
souffre face aux vaches et perdant la
vie et j'ai chopé personne ne croyait
pas le bon succès de la fête de la
musique puis voilà vingt ans plus tard
19 ans pour être très précis
le résultat yann tiersen sur scène face
à plus de 20000 spectateurs
eh ben voilà alors
histoire de bien
pas
quelqu'un ment
le jeu
au sol
m
voilà bonne fête de la musique à vous
tous et vous tout ce soir un petit peu
partout en france nous arrivons à la fin
de cette édition je vous rappelle deux
actualités que nous avons développée que
nous avons proposées dans cette édition
tout d'abord la condamnation par la
justice pour faute inexcusable des
chantiers de l'atlantique dans trois
dossiers de victimes de l'amiante
d'autres personnes victimes de l'amiante
dans les réseaux l'université de jussieu
seront également indemniser et puis
l'exclusivité france 2 avant sa venue
officielle en france lundi le président
syrien bachar al assad nous avait
accordé un entretien à damas le premier
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir pour la
mort de son père bachar el-assad évoque
le départ de l'armée syrienne du liban
il n'évoque pas un winner n'exclut pas
un retrait total de l'armée syrienne et
puis n'est culpin non plus de
reconnaître israël
après un règlement global de la
situation au proche orient
la météo dans quelques instants avec
sophie davant suivi du point route de
valérie maurice et puis je fais un grand
coup
michel drucker qui feront des actifs de
long de cette soirée pour une fête de la
musique spéciale exclusive 39 en pleine
nuit vont trouver jacques cardoze pour
dernier journal demain cette intrigante
dans les 4 vérités gérard noirot se
braque président de la ligue nationale
de football djarbou au point à 13 heures
demain ne manquez pas le dernier journal
présenté par gérard holtz à lundi
bonsoir merci
mais demain vous retrouverez béatrice
schönberg
pour voir la vie en rose
plaisante et 11
dans un super
et les bras pleins de grand santi
tu es le caire
de son monde
c'est qui